بخموت في مرمى موسكو اكثر من اي وقت مضى
في هذه الجبهه تستميت عناصر مجموعه فاجنر
الروسيه في القتال ضد القوات الاوكرانيه
للسيطره على المدينه الاستراتيجيه في
الشرق الاوكراني من جهته يعلن الكرملين عن
تقدم القوات الروسيه لكن في المقابل تؤكد
كياف صمودها في وجه الروس
دمرت المدينه لكنها لا تزال تحت السيطره
القوات الاوكرانيه اوكرانيا
تحولت المعركه الى حرب شوارع تستخدم فيها
الخنادق المحفوره عند سفوح المباني
المدمره وعن هذه المواجهات تقول المخابرات
الالمانيه ان اوكرانيا تخسر المئات من
الرجال كل يوم
معظم السكان في بخموت وفي بلده توريتس
كالمجاوره قرر الفرار الا قله قليله فضلت
البقاء
ليس لدينا غاز ولا ماء بدانا نحصل على
القليل من الكهرباء ولكن الامراه كان
مختلفه في السابق انقطع الكهرباء طيلته
ثلاثه ايام شعرنا بالبرد الحياه بشكل عام
صعبه صعبه جدا وليس هناك اي مكان
في الاثناء تواصل روسيا قصف البنيه
التحتيه للبلاد وتزعم انها استحوذت على
خطوط ومواقع هامه في منطقه زاكوريجيا جنوب
اوكرانيا روايه نفسها كياف مؤكده انها
تصدت لهذا الهجوم الروسي